comment expliquer le retard des vaccins
français sanofi pasteur
ça c'est la grosse question il faut bien
comprendre qu'il ya deux situations il
ya le vaccin de sanofi pasteur
le retard est un retard d'origine
technologies qu'ils ont choisi un mode
d'immunisation basé sur une technique
qui maîtrise bien sûr d expression de
protéines virales et malheureusement ça
n'a pas très bien marché et donc ils
sont obligés effectivement ça des
conduits à prendre pas mal de retard et
puis une deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya
des vaccins qui sont en cours de
développement à l'institut pasteur en
particulier les premières phases
cliniques ont commencé donc ces vaccins
vont arriver le retard a été pris pour
différentes raisons mais le point
important c'est que il faut bien
comprendre qu'on pourrait dans le futur
avoir besoin de ce type de vaccin qui
pourrait peut-être stimuler une immunité
plus prolongée et donner une protection
plus prolongé donc là il ya un retard
mais un retard qui peut être compensée
dans le futur il ya un retard qui encore
une fois est lié à des questions de
financement à des questions
d'organisation de la recherche en france
sur les partenariats public privé ça
c'est clair mais c'est pas forcément un
retard définitif
le retard de sanofi pasteur est vraiment
lié à des problèmes techniques dans la
production et la pose une question de
fond
quant au futur de ce vaccin
[Musique]